California's Democratic Governor Jerry
Brown Governor Brown thanks so much for
joining us appreciate it
okay thank you glad to be here so
yesterday you suggested president
Trump's approach to North Korea was
quote stupid and dangerous and silly I
know you don't care for the term rocket
man about Kim jong-un but to play
devil's advocate is it not possible that
this tactic might work because
everything else has failed with North
Korea from Clinton to Bush to Obama who
tried at the diplomatic way yeah if you
believe in bluster and starting a
bluster war with North Korea which is
what they do and they're pretty darn
good at invective and threats one after
the other so I think bluster is not the
pathway of diplomacy or even
statesmanship sure these are real
serious issues no doubt about it I've
got to work closely with China and
Russia and South Korea and Japan but
just noise and threats we're going to
kill every man woman and she'll a child
in North Korea is that that doesn't
advance the ball it just raises the the
temperature and the exchange of
non-rational bluster back and forth I
don't think that's positive speaking of
raising the temperature you're at the UN
General Assembly with other Democratic
governors to participate in climate week
President Trump we're told aired his
dissatisfaction with the Paris climate
agreement during a meeting with the
French president saying that other
countries namely China received a better
deal than the United States is it not
true that China let China set lower
standards for itself than did the u.s.
look a China is doing more than the u.s.
right now they're closing down coal
plants they're massively investing in
solar and wind they're mastering battery
technology which will help America so
this point that America got a bad deal
is fake it's more fake than any fake
news assertion by by President Trump
this agreement is so fundamental I mean
you watch all these hurricanes and the
devastation you can't take your mind off
extreme weather events that's exactly
what climate change is going to bring
about it may already bring bringing them
about so to omit that an existential
threat climate change that's what it is
it's irresponsible it's blind
it's almost I don't even know how he
gets away with that I have to call that
fake news or whatever you call a
president speech of that order in
reference to climate change this week
you compared Trump supporters to cave
dwellers you said quote you should check
out the derivation of Trump I and
troglodyte because they both refer to
people who dwell in deep dark caves are
you really calling the nearly 63 million
Trump voters cave dwellers no and if you
saw your own words there it was about
Trump ight and troglodyte it wasn't
about the millions of voters who voted
for President Trump many of which are
right in California know the people who
closely advise climate denial advise
bluster wars advice stigmatizing and D
legitimizing our entire news industry as
fake yeah that that is really a calling
cave drawers because cave dwellers
didn't have TV like that but it is a
blindness it's a darkness that evades
the truth it really generates that kind
of disinformation that undermines
democracy and doesn't build dialogue
which we desperately need in this
country and between nations around the
world I want to ask you about some
legislation that you have on your desk
over the weekend California passed a
bill making the golden state a sanctuary
state that's there's no word sanctuary
this is a bill to have the Immigration
Service do their own work and not
attempt to conscript state officials
into being part of the Immigration
Service it does allow close cooperation
on data on drug busts and drug raids and
also working with the Immigration
Service whether it's from our prisons or
from the jails when you're dealing with
serious criminals so it protects Public
Safety but it also protects hard-working
people who contributed a lot to
California hardly hard-working people
who are undocumented immigrants yeah by
the way they've got a couple million
working our agricultural industry our
hospitality industry our construction
industry they're being deep
trouble without those same people and
that's why we need immigration reform
not blessed or not rhetoric and not this
kind of xenophobia that we see too much
of coming out of Washington do you think
that complying with federal immigration
laws are it's optional because that that
would be the counter-argument no no and
we comply with immigration laws where
we're not soldiers of Donald Trump or
the federal Immigration Service we have
our own laws to arrest criminals to give
them a jury trial and then to provide
appropriate punishment that's our job
now the immigration people can come out
of our jails they can interview people
they can pick up people that they think
are appropriate but don't tell
California to do your work in fact there
are many cases of people who the
Immigration Service said they wanted and
they don't even show up to come to get
them so this is a well balanced bill the
police chief of Los Angeles supported
there's a number of law enforcement
officials who said it was a much better
piece of legislation than what was
originally introduced and which got the
name sanctuary city or sanctuary state
another piece of legislation passed in
the California State Legislature Friday
would require presidential candidates to
release their five most recent years of
tax returns in order to be able to get
on the California ballot president Trump
has of course infamously refused to
release his returns he says he's under
audit you also have not released your
tax returns do you plan to sign actually
I did release them in my earlier
campaign so this time around my
opponents wouldn't do it so I didn't
either
I'm not going to tell you what I'll do
in the bill I want to read it I want to
look at the legality and in the face of
federal law so we'll take a look at it I
generally don't opine on the six hundred
bills that the legislature leaves on my
desk I take a look at each one I'll give
this a fair read and you'll hear my
decision very soon
all right California Governor Jerry
Brown thanks so much really appreciate